cohorts and heated floors drizzy is
kicking off ovo world weekend with
canadian flair he posts this to
instagram writing quote a celebration of
music that paved the way for all of us
i've been telling everybody like i'm
going to blow the roof off of that place
and it's going to be a very patriotic
celebration shawn desmond carnell
official chocolate julie black and our
very own keisha shantae will hit the
stage tonight invited by the king of the
416. i got a call from like one of his
boys
um
basically being like hey
drake's putting together the show he
wants you to be a part of it you're down
i'm like let me think about that for a
second
so it was like automatic let's do it i
don't care whatever you know what i mean
it's going to be kind of like a high
school reunion
you know grown people summer camp type
thing it's going to be high energy it's
going to be everything that people know
and i'm just like
i'm like super stoked about it like i
cannot wait rumor has it there's gonna
be an after party that's crazy so you
know this is where i'm gonna have to
maybe take a nap
beforehand